JUSTIN: I'm Justin, tech
lead for the WebRTC project
at Google.
And today, we're going
to talk about using audio
in the web platform.
The web platform has come a long
way on both mobile and desktop.
And using technologies like the
Media Capture API, Web Audio,
and WebRTC, it's now super easy
to record, process, and send
audio and video in your app.
To demonstrate this,
we're going to try
something we've
never done before.
We're going to use this
session to record a theme
song for Google I/O. And
you're going to help.
So I'm pretty jazzed about this.
I played in some bands back
in the day, a little keyboard,
a bit of bass.
And I remember what it was
like to make music back then.
To get that perfect
sound, we had
to tote around a whole bunch
of gear, all sorts of effects
pedals-- overdrive, chorus,
flanger, wah-wah-- amps and EQs
to get the right tone, and a
four track to record it all.
And that was a big
investment for us.
But that's what it took to
sound like real rock stars.
So we'd all have been
blown away to know
that this whole basement
of audio processing gear
would soon be able to be
replaced by a web browser.
In the modern web
platform, we now
have the power to
do incredible things
with media on any device.
And one great example of
this is a new third party
app called Soundtrap.
Built on Web Audio,
WebRTC, and Dart,
this app is like a set of
instruments, a recording
studio, and a musical
collaboration tool
all rolled into one.
And we're going to use
it to record our song.
So musical inspiration can
strike you at any time.
So imagine I'm just sitting
on the train with my Nexus 7,
and I get the idea
for a great song.
So let me show you
how this works.
I'll plug in the Nexus 7.
Let's make this real.
So I'm running the Soundtrap
app in Chrome for Android.
And the first thing we need
is a driving percussion track.
So let me go ahead and check
out the drum loops we have here
and figure out what's the
right thing for our song.
[BEAT PLAYING]
Mm, let's see what else.
I think I want something
that has a bit more rock.
[BEAT PLAYING]
Yeah, OK, that's the one.
So let me just tap that and
add that to our song-- perfect.
OK, so we've got our
percussion track.
But now, to complete
our rhythm section,
we need to get a
bass line going.
So fortunately, I've
just arrived home,
where I've got my bass.
And now, using the Media
Capture API, also known
as getUserMedia, I can
record my instrument right
inside my laptop.
So let me show you
how this works.
I'm going to plug in here
just using a standard cable
right into the microphone
jack on my laptop--
no special hardware or cables.
And there's my drum track I
already added from before.
All right, I got
a sweet bass amp.
[BASS PLAYING]
Let me just make sure
I'm in tune here.
[BASS TUNING]
All right, perfect.
All right, let me just play a
couple notes to get started.
This one might sound
kind of familiar,
although our
attorneys have told us
that it can't
sound too familiar.
[BASS PLAYING]
All right, how does that sound?
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
This is sounding great.
And this is simply
incredible to have
this kind of power
in a web application.
So let's go ahead and record
a bass line for our song.
So right here in Soundtrap, I'm
just going to start recording.
And I'm going to
add this bass line
right on top of the drum
part that we had before.
[BASS PLAYING OVER DRUMS]
All right, I was a
little bit early on that.
So let me try that
one more time.
[BASS PLAYING OVER DRUMS]
All right, so there we've
got our great bass line.
Let's save that out.
And that's what we've
got for our bass track.
So onto our next
part-- let's talk
about the technology
behind what we just did.
So in the Media Capture
API, the key method
is called getUserMedia.
And this call opens up
the microphone-- oops.
This call opens up the
microphone, asking the user
for permission the first time,
and gives us a Media Stream
object that represents the
audio coming from my bass.
Now, the same
getUserMedia API can also
be used to get access to
the microphone for speech
or a webcam for video.
Now normally, when we call
getUserMedia to get access
to the mic, the
mic signal is going
to get routed through a
bunch of processing stages
to make sure we get
a good speech signal.
Now, we're also going
to apply auto gain
control to make sure
the levels are correct,
as well as acoustic
echo cancellation
to make sure any of the sound
coming out from the speakers
doesn't also get
picked up by the mic.
However, when we're
recording an instrument,
we don't want any
of that processing
to occur so we get as pure
of a tone as possible.
So when we call getUserMedia,
we're going to turn that off.
So here's a typical
call to getUserMedia.
We make it on the
Navigator object.
And we ask, in this
case, for a media stream
that contains
audio from the mic.
We'll get our stream
back asynchronously.
And then, we can actually
do something with it.
If the syntax looks
kind of unfamiliar here,
this is making use of
Dart's Future concept.
The .then at the end of the
statement allows us to say
easily what should get executed
when we get our stream back.
So when we call
getUserMedia, we're
now going to specify
the parameters
we want to the audio stream.
And here, we're going
to ask for audio
and specify we want the
AEC turned off-- simple.
So this way, it's what we're
doing inside of Soundtrap
to get access to the microphone
to record bass, guitar,
or any other instrument.
And now, let's turn
it up a little bit.
Because Media Capture
is really cool.
But it totally
comes to life when
we connect it with
a Web Audio API.
And that's where we can do
some amazing audio processing.
So to demonstrate this, let
me welcome Per on stage.
Per is one of the
co-founders of Soundtrap.
[APPLAUSE]
Per.
Is one of the
co-founders of Soundtrap,
and also a bit of a guitar hero.
PER: Hi, Justin.
JUSTIN: Great to have
you here on stage, Per.
PER: Thank you very
much for having us.
JUSTIN: So do you think you
could play a couple guitar
riffs for us?
PER: Maybe I can do that.
I have a guitar [INAUDIBLE],
so let me mic up.
JUSTIN: So Per is going to
play some guitar for us.
And we're going to use that to
demonstrate the effects that
are possible using Web Audio.
PER: So we're using
Web Audio to build up
a whole set of effects.
And I'll show you
some of the presets
that we have if I get
some volume, yeah?
So this is just an acoustic
sound with no effects
on at all.
[GUITAR PLAYING]
Like-- and then we
can do something else.
JUSTIN: All right, let's
go a little harder.
[DISTORTED GUITAR PLAYING]
We call that one--
[APPLAUSE]
We call that one
"Fumes on the Ocean."
So let's kick it into overdrive.
[OVERDRIVE GUITAR PLAYING]
We call that one
"Insane Bus Ride."
Is that right?
PER: Yeah, something like that.
JUSTIN: OK, all right,
now let's take it back
to the origins of rock and roll.
[SLAP DELAYED GUITAR PLAYING]
OK, ladies and gentlemen, Per.
[APPLAUSE]
So to have this kind
of processing power
on the web-- simply fantastic.
Let's talk about the magic
behind these effects.
PER: Yeah, so let's talk about
this simple one, actually.
So this is called
a slap back effect.
[SLAP DELAYED GUITAR PLAYING]
Exactly, that's right.
JUSTIN: So most of
you are probably
familiar with the HTML5
audio and video elements that
load, decode, and play
out audio and video.
But Web Audio goes
beyond that and gives you
super low delay
and precise control
over each one of
these steps, including
scheduling sounds down to
sampling level accuracy.
And this time is particularly
important for games, as well as
pro audio apps like Soundtrap.
Web Audio also allows
powerful synthesis,
processing, and routing tools.
So this lets us do all sorts
of great stuff, everything
you see here-- synthesizers,
effects, visualizers--
everything you
need for pro audio.
So from the API
perspective, Web Audio
is based on a simple
concept-- the audio pipeline.
And in the API, we refer to this
pipeline as an AudioContext.
We can build out our pipeline
by taking inputs either
from a file, microphone,
or synthesizer,
and processing it using
what we call nodes.
And these nodes can do
various different things.
They can apply gain.
They can apply delay.
They can even send the
data to JavaScript,
where JavaScript can
change the sample values.
Finally, we send it all
out to a destination--
typically the audio output.
Now I'm going to
hand it over to Per
to explain how we get
from this to this.
PER: Yeah, so now I'm going
to show you the slap back.
So that was a very
simple effect.
So you can hear it here.
So there's a direct
signal, and then
one small delayed
signal after that.
[SLAP DELAYED GUITAR PLAYING]
OK, you can hear that?
So that can be represented
in a diagram like this.
So we have the audio
coming from the guitar,
and then routed
directly to the speaker.
That's the up line.
And then, we're adding
one delay signal.
And then we gain that.
We lower the volume a
little bit on that one.
So then you will have that
very simple effect, yeah?
So the good thing
with Web Audio is
that it makes it very
easy to actually program
effects like this.
Because you have all the
different types of nodes
you would like to combine.
And you can do that
in very simple ways.
So I will just show
you the code here
that you can use to implement
[INAUDIBLE] like this.
So first, we need
to get the context.
We talked about that.
So you're getting the context.
And you will use that
object to, for example,
create the nodes later on.
And then we're also
getting the user media.
So that was what we
just showed before.
So once we get the
user media back,
we'll start by actually
creating the guitar node here
by using the Context
object, and then just
call createMediaStreamSource
on that stream
that we returned from
the getUserMedia.
And then, we also get the
reference to the speaker.
So then, we have our
two nodes to connect.
Then, we just hook the
first two up together.
So we say, guitar
connect to speaker.
So then we have the
direct path here.
Then, we're using the context
again to create a delay.
So that's all in the
Web Audio API here.
So we create the delay node.
And then we hook the guitar
up with the delay node.
And then again,
we use the context
object to create the gain node.
And then we hook the delay
up with the gain node.
And then we connect the
gain node with the speaker.
So it's not many
lines of code you
need to actually create
an effect like that.
Then, of course, that's one
of the more simpler ones.
So we have much more
complex ones that we show.
So that's the whole
snippet you need, OK?
JUSTIN: OK, so now we're
going to add a lead guitar
part to our song.
And to get a great
guitar sound, we're
going to combine a whole
pipeline of the effects
that Per just demonstrated.
We're going to add delay,
chorus, compression,
and fuzz to create
a truly sweet tone.
So let me show you
how that works.
[GUITAR PLAYING WITH EFFECTS]
PER: Yeah, something like that.
But what we're going
to do now, we're
going to play some
melody on top of our song
that we're building up.
And I would like you to
try to remember that.
Because you could be asked later
on to actually remember it,
just to let you know.
JUSTIN: All right,
that's a great sound.
Per, give us a killer melody.
PER: Yeah.
JUSTIN: Here we go.
[TRACK PLAYING]
[GUITAR PLAYING WITH EFFECTS]
JUSTIN: All right.
PER: Simple, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
JUSTIN: That was rocking.
PER: Think you
can remember that?
Try to remember that.
JUSTIN: All right, we've got
all our parts right here.
OK, so the next thing
we need for our song
is a groovy keyboard part.
And unfortunately, we don't
have any keyboard players
hiding backstage.
But Per, do you know
anyone who plays keys?
PER: Actually, I do.
As a matter of fact, our
founder and CTO Bjorn
is rather good at
keyboard, actually.
JUSTIN: Huh, do you think
he could play for us?
PER: So what if I call him up?
JUSTIN: Well, let's do that.
So over in Soundtrap,
we have the ability
to invite Bjorn to our song.
Let's see if he can help us out.
Soundtrap is located
in Stockholm.
So I guess it might
take a little while.
PER: So Bjorn just
joined the chat.
JUSTIN: OK, great.
Well, let's see if he
can help us out here.
PER: Hi, Bjorn.
BJORN: Hi, Justin.
Hi, Per.
PER: Hi, how are you?
BJORN: I'm fine.
How are you?
PER: Very good, thanks.
JUSTIN: So Per tells me
you play a little keys.
And that's just what
we need for a song.
We're here at Google
I/O recording a song,
a theme song for
Google I/O. Do you
think maybe you
could help us out?
BJORN: Well, you know, I
have this MIDI keyboard here.
So I can give it a try.
It's just a regular
MIDI keyboard.
And it's connected to my
laptop using a USB cable.
So I'm going to be
recording some organ here.
And this is all done
using the Web Media API.
So let's see here, I'm
going to be adding a track.
Let's see if we can get some--
[ORGAN PLAYING]
JUSTIN: All right.
BJORN: So did you hear that?
JUSTIN: Yep.
BJORN: Cool, so here we go then.
I'm going to record something.
[ORGAN PLAYING OVER TRACK]
Now let me just save that.
JUSTIN: All right.
PER: Very good, thanks.
BJORN: So there you go.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
JUSTIN: So that
was really great.
Do you think maybe you could
help us out a bit more,
maybe add a few backing
tracks to the song?
BJORN: Yeah sure, why not?
Let me give it a try.
JUSTIN: OK.
Well, Bjorn is also
in our project.
And so it's in the cloud.
And we'll be notified
when his updates are
finished so we can
check them out.
All right, so let's talk
about what we just saw there.
We did collaboration onstage.
We did collaboration
with WebRTC.
WebRTC is all
about communication
and collaboration,
the ability to connect
with anyone, any time, anywhere.
And to be able to make music
together collaboratively,
this is a perfect use of WebRTC.
Now technically, WebRTC
provides apps with an API
to establish a real-time
peer to peer connection.
And in using that
connection, you
can send audio, video,
or arbitrary data.
Now, the API that we used for
making this P2P connection
is called, naturally,
Peer Connection.
And if you take
the media streams
that we got earlier
using getUserMedia,
we can now attach these
to a Peer Connection.
And the Peer
Connection will take
care of the hard work of setting
up a peer to peer connection
and streaming that audio and
video across the network.
And this all works great, even
on the real world internet,
as you heard from Bjorn.
Now Soundtrap, for the musical
collaboration you just saw,
they needed a few more
extra features from WebRTC.
So Per, can you tell
us more about that?
PER: Yeah sure, so
there's like three things
we need to be able to
do this in a good way.
So the use case
for us is that we
will need to be able to hear
what he is playing, of course.
We need to be able
to speak with him.
And we need to be able
to see him, right?
So we need to have a
video chat functionality.
We need to have high
quality stereo audio.
And we need to have the
input that was already
kind of processed in Web Audio.
So if I were playing
with my guitar,
I can have a multitude
of effects added on.
So I need to have that also
heard over the network.
Bjorn here was playing
our synthesizer.
And that is also
done using Web Audio.
So we heard that, the organ.
So here's kind of
the setup we need.
So we need the input
from the upper part
here, which is the stuff
we already showed you,
and the effects or any
synthesizers or anything
created using Web Audio.
We need the input from
the actual computer mic.
So that needs to be mixed in
with the other stuff coming
from Web Audio.
And then, we need
the webcam stream.
And we put that into
the Peer Connection.
And then the magic
happens, yeah?
So let's look at
the code for that.
So we're using the
getUserMedia API again here.
But instead of
fetching the audio,
we're fetching the video part.
And when that is returning,
then the then clause
here is executed.
So the first thing-- if
you see in the bottom here,
we have actually received an
access to our webcam stream.
Then, we are taking the
musicOut object, which
is the output and
the mix of everything
we've done in Web Audio,
including the mic,
and we create a
MediaStream destination
using that musicOut object.
And then, we're getting
the stream for that.
So then, we have our
stereo music stream.
Then, we are hooking up
both the stereo music stream
and the webcam stream
to the Peer Connection.
So this is also
Dart syntax, so we
can use the dot
dot notation here.
And once we have
added the stereo music
stream and the webcam stream
to the Peer Connection,
we just start to call
on the Peer Connection.
And then they start to talk
to each other, the two peers,
right?
JUSTIN: Very cool.
PER: Very good.
JUSTIN: So that's all
about Peer Connection.
So now let's go see
if Bjorn is finished
adding those backing tracks.
It seems like we're waiting
for a second on those backing
tracks.
So while we're waiting, a
proton walks into a bar.
He sees an electron
sitting there and says,
I feel there's an
attraction between us.
PER: Yeah, here it is.
JUSTIN: All right, so now
we've got these backing tracks.
Let's go and check out
what our song sounds like.
Here we go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JUSTIN: What do you think?
[APPLAUSE]
PER: Quite cool.
JUSTIN: OK, but we're missing
one thing-- the vocals.
And so we've
collaborated on stage.
We've collaborated
across the internet.
And now, we're going to do
some collaboration with you.
So you're all going to sing
the vocals for the song.
And I'm going to go out in
the audience and record it.
And to do that, I've got
my Nexus 5 right here.
And I'm logged into Soundtrap
using Chrome for Android.
Now, Per's singing voice
is a little bit better
than me-- classically trained.
And so he's going
to lead you on this.
Per?
PER: Yeah, yeah, sure, sure.
So I told you to
remember the melody part.
So we're actually going to put
some lyrics on top of that.
And you may imagine already,
so it's Google I/O, Google I/O,
Google I/O, Google
I/O four times, OK?
So it's quite easy.
JUSTIN: If you forget,
it's like right here.
PER: So what we'll do is
you've heard the song now
a couple of times.
So we'll do a rehearsal first.
And when we rehearse, after the
second time we have sung it,
we'll actually turn
down the volume.
But you should continue
singing anyway with me, right?
And then we'll do a take
after that, promise.
Sing from your toes,
as we say in Swedish.
[SPEAKING SWEDISH], yeah, OK?
OK, let's try it.
Should we--
JUSTIN: All right.
PER: Play, yeah?
JUSTIN: Here we go.
PER: I'll take the
practice round first.
JUSTIN: OK, here we go.
PER: One moment.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SINGING] Google I/O-- help me
out-- Google I/O, Google I/O,
Google I/O.
So that's how it's going to be.
That was a practice round.
Now you know.
We're going to be-- we'll try
to record it on the Nexus 5.
So you can lean over
to that one as well.
Because there's the mic.
Let's do it, then.
JUSTIN: All right, that
sounded pretty good.
But I think they can
be a little louder.
PER: Yeah.
JUSTIN: That was maybe singing
from the knees, not quite
the toes.
PER: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
JUSTIN: All right,
so one more time.
Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUDIENCE: [SINGING] Google
I/O, Google I/O, Google I/O,
Google I/O.
PER: Great.
[APPLAUSE]
Very good.
JUSTIN: You guys were fantastic.
PER: Definitely.
JUSTIN: That was
definitely all the way down
to the soles of the feet.
All right, so we're
now going to kick off
the final mix down for the song.
And so while we
wait for that, let's
talk about what Soundtrap needed
from an application platform.
In building a cloud-based
musical collaboration app,
Soundtrap knew they
needed a platform that
was familiar to
their developers,
and yet would scale as the
project became more complex.
And as a small
startup, they also
want to make sure
their developers could
be as productive as possible.
So I want to talk
about these in turn.
This is why
Soundtrap chose Dart,
a new platform for
scalable web engineering.
Let's look at what Dart provides
that makes it so attractive.
First, familiarity-- Dart
feels like JavaScript.
Semicolons, curly braces
for a reason, classes,
single inheritance-- everything
familiar to people who are
using JavaScript or other
languages like Java or C++.
And because of that, Dart
was designed explicitly
to be easy to learn.
Google's run numerous internal
and external hackathons.
And everybody picks
it up super fast.
Now, the Dart team also
took the opportunity
to go a bit beyond JavaScript
to clean some things up.
While Dart is familiar, it also
makes things easy and terse.
So here, we're
declaring the user class
with two fields--
username and password.
This code sample should
look very natural.
We can also add things
like name constructors.
You can create
different constructors
with different names.
And it's very
clear what they do.
We can also add getters and
setters when you need them.
And we can do a simple
getter in just one line.
You can look at this fat
arrow syntax where we check,
is this username valid?
Super easy to write single
line functions and methods.
Now let's address scalability.
Typical web app development
starts out as small scripts
and grows to very
large, complicated apps.
But we want to make
sure as that app grows
from 100 to 100,000
lines of code,
the environment is there with
you to help you scale up.
So Soundtrap started out
just like this-- few files
and scripts.
And they grew over time.
But they made use of stuff like
Dart's libraries and packages
to keep things organized.
As the app grew in size,
the Soundtrap engineers
didn't have to slow
their productivity.
Here, Dart can bundle
code into libraries.
And libraries are
like modules of code.
And from the dart:async
library, we're going to pull
in the Future class.
We've seen futures before
when we used getUserMedia.
And futures are
these objects that
represent things
that don't exist yet.
But they will in
the future, get it?
So they're much easier
than call backs.
And so also, like other
structured languages,
Dart classes can
have static methods.
Here, our load method is
going to return a future that
will resolve when the back end
service completes its query.
Last, let's talk
about productivity.
Soundtrap is able
to be productive
because tools like the Dart
Editor and the Dart Analyzer
are able to statically
analyze the code.
Because of things
like static typing,
they can provide
real-time feedback
when you do something wrong.
Here, we're notified
immediately by the Dart Editor
that we misspelled a field.
We don't need to go run
our app or fail our unit
test to know that we
did something wrong.
The tools tell us proactively.
And as the code grows to
many packages and libraries,
it's really hard for a developer
to keep all of the APIs
in their head.
And the Dart Editor
comes in handy there.
The Dart Editor gives
this real-time code
completion like any sort
of modern, mature IDE.
Last, because of the static
typing and static [INAUDIBLE]
analysis, the tools know
what types the objects are.
The developer can
always stay in the flow.
So Dart-- familiarity,
scalability, productivity.
Now let's talk to Per.
You guys worked with this.
Can you talk more about
what specifically Dart
helped you do?
PER: This is one
of many examples,
of course, why Dart
is so important for us
and good for us.
So we've seen it
now a couple times.
We need to load the project
and the tracks in the project.
And it's a cloud-based service.
So we would like to do that
as fast as possible because we
synchronize in between
the devices all the time.
Asynchronous program is a little
bit tricky in other languages,
like for example JavaScript.
But it makes it very easy using
the Future mechanism in Dart.
So let's say that we have a
project with three tracks.
So we define a
method loadProject,
which returns a future.
And then, when the HTTP request
here actually also returns
a future, when that is
done, then we parse to JSON.
So that is what is
done in this method.
Then, we define a second
method to load the audio
and do exactly the same thing.
But we decode in the
audio data, the blob.
So then, we hook
the two methods up.
So first, we load the project.
And when it's executed
loading the project,
and then we have our
kind of information
about the product and the
tracks, then we return.
We will have the
project instance here.
So we can work on that.
And then, we're using something
that's called a wait method.
That means that
everything-- so you
can pass in a list of futures.
And when all the
futures have executed,
their job actually continues.
So in the Future.wait method,
we pass in a list of futures
from the loadAudio method.
And that can also be done
very neatly in Dart here.
So we have the project instance.
We're calling the tracks.
And we're using something that's
called a map, which actually
collects all the futures
from the loadAudio method
calls into a list and pass
that into the Future.wait.
So it's quite a very
dense way of doing
asynchronous programming.
OK.
JUSTIN: So Soundtrap is a great
demonstration of the modern web
platform using
APIs covering media
capture, audio processing,
real-time communication,
and more.
But these APIs aren't
just for Chrome.
These APIs belong
to the open web.
And they're available on
multiple modern browsers
on both mobile and desktop.
So for example, Web Audio is
available on over 2 billion
devices, of which over
a billion are mobile,
including Android and iOS.
WebRTC-- over 1.5
billion browsers
and 300 million mobile devices.
We're seeing great growth
across the WebRTC ecosystem
on both desktop and mobile
with multiple major players
shipping apps built on WebRTC.
Some examples--
Snapchat's video chat,
powered by WebRTC, TokBox,
and Amazon's Mayday service,
all powered by the
WebRTC platform.
I've also been in touch with
all the major WebRTC app
developers.
And there's going to be several
more major announcements later
this year.
Finally, we're super excited
to announce that in Android L,
the WebView v36 fully supports
Web Audio and WebRTC, allowing
those building native apps
to bring these technologies
to the over 1 billion
Android 30 day active users.
[APPLAUSE]
So the mixing is finished.
Let's come full circle
back to my Nexus
7 and listen to our song.
Well, it looks like our Nexus 7
has decided it has other plans.
That's no problem.
Here we go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JUSTIN: So give
yourselves a hand.
You guys were fantastic.
Thanks for singing.
And if you want to
listen again, you
can download the song
from the Soundtrap site.
[APPLAUSE]
So now that we've got you
all inspired about what
the modern web
platform can do, you
can try it out for yourselves.
If you haven't already
checked it out,
come get your hands dirty at the
WebRTC Code Lab, running here
at I/O until the end of today,
and also available later
online.
There are also some great
resources on WebRTC,
Web Audio, and Dart written
by experts in an excellent way
to try out these technologies.
And that wraps up our
session for today.
Now we want to hear from you.
You can give us
feedback on the session
at the address listed here.
And we also have a few minutes
to take audience requests,
I mean questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PER: Thank you very
much, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So first of all,
thank you for the great talk.
It was very inspiring.
And the song is really cool.
I wanted to ask about
audio latency on Android.
Did you get it low enough?
JUSTIN: So that's a bit
of a work in progress
I'll have to tell you.
We've made a lot of improvements
to latency through ICS, Jelly
Bean and KitKat.
We're still not
to the point where
we can get the--
what we really want
is like 20 millisecond
latency on Android.
We're doing a lot of work there,
including being able to expose
all the APIs through OpenSL,
through the C++ layer,
so that we can have the
minimum latency possible.
So we're not where
we want to be yet.
But we're spending a
ton of energy on it.
AUDIENCE: For L, are
we going to have it?
JUSTIN: Ah, I'm not going
to make any promises.
Just we're working
very hard on it.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I
missed the beginning.
Maybe you guys touched on this.
But I was curious
about MIDI support
and being able to
hook up a synth
and maybe get down with the
piano or organ or something
like that.
PER: Yeah, it's Web MIDI, which
is also part of the standard.
So we hook up the MIDI
directly to the USB port.
JUSTIN: Right, so
Web MIDI is kind
of a very nascent standard.
It's supported
provisionally within Chrome.
We hope to promote it in
the next version or two
to be full API and see it
picked up by other browsers.
But you saw Web MIDI
in action here when
they played the keys part.
And Soundtrap is making
full use of this.
And it is a great API
in the web platform.
PER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, what
kind of server side
is included in this demo?
So I wanted to ask how the
tracks are joined together
when you publish the
track, the project.
PER: How they work together?
AUDIENCE: On the server
side or on the client side
here in Soundtrap?
PER: Yeah, so the music is
stored on the server side,
yeah.
But then, it pushed
out to the client.
So we're using a
Play framework--
I don't know if you know
that-- on the server side.
But it's Dart on
the client side.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PER: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: It's mixed online?
PER: It's mixed on the server.
But when you play
it in the studio,
it's played directly
on the client.
But the last mix that you heard
was mixed on the server, right?
JUSTIN: Right, so in the actual
editor, when all the tracks are
being played, it
plays in the client.
But when we do the final mix
down to make the actual output
MP3 file, then
that's going to go
and be done by
the cloud service.
PER: I see, this is
only the [INAUDIBLE].
JUSTIN: Oh, right.
So when we're in
here in the studio--
PER: Everything here is
played directly in the client,
in the studio.
So if I-- oh, now we have
no audio anymore, I think.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So that's played
directly on the client.
Yeah.
JUSTIN: OK, thank you,
everyone, for coming.
Have a great rest of I/O.
[APPLAUSE]